21 شهيد اغلبهم كما ترون من الاطفال
والنساء 21 شهيد اعيد واكرر الان ارى
امامي خمس جتد
لاطفال منهم من دون الثالثه من العمر
وكذلك خمس الى سبع سنوات كذلك امراه امراه
امراه امراه واحد الاطباء اللي هو
الدكتور سامي البغدادي اضافه الى الان
خمسه ينتقل الينا من المستشفى الكويتي
التي كانت بالقرب من الاستهداف فلذلك قامت
السيارات الاسب بالنقل اليها يعني لا لا
يسعنا الا ان
نقول اين الامن والامان الذي يدعيه جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اين المناطق الامنه
التي ادعى انها امنه وكذلك نصح او وجه
الناس للنزوح اليها فهذه مقوله ان هناك في
مناطق امنه في قطاع غزه هي خدعه كما ترون
اطفال ونساء فاين المقاومين من هؤلاء اين
من يدعي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انه يقصف
مناطق ارهابيه ها هي بنك الاهداف
الاسرائيلي كما ترون بنك الاهداف للجيش
الاسرائيلي اطفال هل هذا هو العدل هل هذا
هو مصير ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني العدو
الاسرائيلي يرتكب اباده جماعيه في حق
ابناء شعبنا
الفلسطيني